but now new jersey you're from new
jersey and when you were filming west
side story yeah new jersey royalty came
to call yes
descended from the heavens bruce
springsteen
and yeah bruce springsteen came three
times and he came to see me sing i feel
pretty and he had his his aviators on
he's like gotta see the jersey girl sing
and i just peed my pants
and there it is yeah i was losing my
mind i couldn't go that day i could not
go up and talk to him it was him and
stephen sondheim sitting next to each
other i was like what why am i here
was that still the same day that barack
obama came as well barack obama came i
like that he gets third billing
it was barack obama's bruce springsteen
john williams all on the same day
it was just absolutely ridiculous but
how did it work do they sit and work
with monitors or were they like in the
scene they watched us um they watched
gustavo dudamel who's an incredible
conductor a maestro in his in his own
right truly and he they watched him
conduct the mambo with the new york
philharmonic and it's i'm sitting there
on the couch and michelle obama's next
to me and bruce springsteen's there and
barack obama and john williams and
steven spielberg and john williams is
talking to gustavo dudamel and john
turns to barack obama and says well what
do you think and i'm like well what does
it matter when he thinks he was the
president of the united states
just the most ridiculous i can't even
believe i was sitting in that it sounds
like you're describing one of those
really like dreams like
artwork you see at a hotel of the most
famous people ever they're all in there
[Music]
oh they're the dogs playing poker it was
just i can't even today just telling
this story i'm like
what was i doing
[Music]
you